[Música]
la policía de Israel detuvo a un
adolescente palestino que abrió fuego e
hirió a dos personas en Jerusalén este
un nuevo episodio de tensión tras el
tiroteo cerca de una sinagoga que causó
siete muertos y tras la redada del
ejército israelí más mortífera en años
que dejó nueve muertos en la discordia
ocupada donde las fuerzas militares de
Israel han aumentado su pie de fuerza
la presidencia de Perú lamentó que el
congreso rechazara adelantar las
elecciones generales a 2023 de momento
los comicios continúan previstos para
2026 pero El Ejecutivo Pide a los
legisladores pensar en el bien del país
y ceder a uno de los principales
reclamos de las protestas tenemos
reportes de Lima
los combates de la guerra en Ucrania se
intensifican en la línea del frente del
donbash este sábado
Moscú acusó a Ucrania de matar a 14
personas en un hospital de lugangs
señaló que un ataque con misiles rusos
causó la muerte de tres civiles
endoniasco
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición informativa en
Jerusalén porque según la policía de
Israel este sábado un adolescente
palestino hirió con arma de fuego a dos
hombres judíos dos civiles dispararon
también al menor palestino quien resultó
herido y posteriormente fue detenido por
las fuerzas israelíes el incidente
ocurre en medio del aumento de la
violencia en el conflicto derivado de la
ocupación israelí este viernes se
registró un ataque a las afueras de una
sinagoga en Jerusalén este un hecho que
causó siete muertos después de que el
jueves el ejército israelí ejecutará la
redada más mortífera en años en la
discordia ocupada
en la cisjordania ocupada la espiral de
violencia no Da señales de terminar fue
aquí en Jerusalén este la parte de la
ciudad Santa ocupada por Israel desde
1967 donde un adolescente palestino
disparó e hirió a dos personas este
sábado
por lo que entendemos se trata de una
emboscada de un terrorista de 13 años
esperó para emboscar a civiles que se
encontraban en la zona el ataque se
produjo contra cinco personas que hacían
sus oraciones tenemos dos civiles en
estado crítico un padre y un hijo el
agresor por su parte está bajo custodia
policial luego de que dos civiles
lograran herirlo tras el ataque
en estos momentos el terrorista se
encuentra en el hospital donde fue
enviado por las fuerzas y lo que sabemos
es que se trata de un aumento
significativo en el nivel del terror el
atentado se produce en el contexto de
una repentina escalada del conflicto
palestino israelí el viernes un
palestino de 21 años residente en
Jerusalén este disparó y siete fieles
cerca de una sinagoga antes de ser
abatido por la policía ataques que se
cree son en represalia luego de que el
ejército israelí llevara a cabo su
incursión más Sangrienta en sus Jordania
en dos décadas asesinando el 26 de enero
a nueve palestinos en el campo de
refugiados de jenning estos dramáticos
acontecimientos obligaron a cambiar la
agenda de la visita oficial del
secretario de estado Anthony blinquen a
Israel y a los territorios palestinos se
espera que el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense dialogue a puertas
cerrada con el gobierno israelí de
extrema derecha cuyas políticas
preocupan a la Casa Blanca
vamos con noticias de nuestra región
porque la presidencia de Perú lamentó
que el congreso haya rechazado la
propuesta de adelantar las elecciones
generales a octubre de 2023 un proyecto
de ley que presentó el gobierno de Dina
boluarte y que se hundió en el
legislativo con 65 votos en contra este
sábado la presidencia publicó un mensaje
de Twitter en el que pide a los
congresistas que piensen en el interés
nacional dado que el adelanto electoral
así como la renuncia de boluarte son las
principales demandas de las protestas de
hecho la bancada oficialista solicitó
que el proyecto se vuelva a votar el
próximo lunes este fue el tuit
lamentamos que el congreso de la
República no haya logrado ponerse de
acuerdo para definir la fecha de las
elecciones generales donde las peruanas
y peruanos puedan elegir libre y
democráticamente a las nuevas
autoridades exhortamos a las bancadas a
deponer sus intereses partidarios y
grupales Y colocar por encima los
intereses del Perú nuestra ciudadanas y
ciudadanos esperan con prontitud una
respuesta clara que permita allanar una
salida a la crisis política y construir
la paz social
y previamente nuestro corresponsal en
Lima Francisco Zacarías nos explicaba
Cuáles son las alternativas del gobierno
de Dina boluarte si este lunes el
congreso de Perú vuelve a rechazar la
propuesta ejecutiva de adelantar las
elecciones generales
Fuentes consultadas para este reporte me
afirman que la presidenta Dina boluarte
estaría evaluando las estrategias a
seguir para que el congreso de Perú
defina El adelanto de las elecciones la
más importante de ellas sería enviar al
Primer Ministro Alberto tarola al
congreso para que haga cuestión de
confianza y pida al poder legislativo
que defina el adelanto electoral en el
caso extremo que el congreso de este
país niegue dos pedidos de confianza la
presidenta Dina boluarte queda
facultalmente capacitada para disolver
el congreso y ella misma convocar a un
adelanto de las elecciones para este
2023 algunos analistas coinciden en que
la única salida para que Paulo arte
saque adelante de la Reforma que visto
por todos el parlamento peruano no tiene
voluntad de atender desoyendo el pedido
de los peruanos en especial los
manifestantes que tienen en jaque a este
país con los bloqueos y las protestas
que han ocasionado la muerte de más de
50 personas y también han producido más
de 1500 heridos
continuamos en el continente americano
este viernes el vídeo de la paliza que
el afroamericano Nichols recibió de
manos de varios agentes de policía
conmocionó a Estados Unidos y generó
protestas pacíficas en distintos puntos
del país Nichols murió tras sucumbir a
sus heridas y los agentes involucrados y
han sido imputados por asesinato en
segundo grado más de dos años después
del asesinato de George Floyd en otro
acto de violencia policial Defensores de
los derechos humanos se declaran
frustrados Gabriel colchen nos cuenta
más
protestas tuvieron lugar en varias
ciudades de Estados Unidos en reacciona
el vídeo de la muerte de tyricles El
afroamericano de 29 años falleció tras
recibir múltiples golpes por parte de
cinco policías también afrodescendientes
luego de haber sido detenido por una
infracción de tráfico
hemos visto durante años y décadas que
los policías afroamericanos han hecho
por su trabajo lo mismo y han servido al
mismo sistema de supremacía blanca y del
capital Así que es enfermizo es
repugnante pero están haciendo su
trabajo están haciendo lo que vinieron a
hacer que es aterrorizar a las
comunidades para mantener el control
la indignación por este nuevo hecho de
violencia policial es aún mayor ya que
casos como este siguen sucediendo dos
años después del asesinato de George
Floyd el hombre afroamericano que murió
producto de la asfixia que fue sometido
por el oficial en mayo de 2020 su muerte
generó una ola de en todo el país
este año o justo el año pasado vimos las
tasas más altas de asesinatos policiales
en este país no vamos a tolerarlo en
2020 tomamos las calles y nos quedamos
en las calles millones de personas en
este país lideraron un levantamiento y
vamos a hacer lo que haga falta No solo
para que se haga justicia sino para
asegurarnos de que esta brutalidad llega
a su fin de una vez por todas según un
recuento del Washington post 2022 fue el
año más mortífero en Estados Unidos
respecto a la violencia policial en los
últimos 12 meses 1110 personas han
muerto por disparos de fuerzas de
seguridad
proporcionalmente los afroamericanos
mueren a manos de la policía dos veces
más que los estadounidenses blancos
cambiamos de información porque tras 11
meses de Invasión rusa de Ucrania los
combates se intensifican en la zona del
Don vaso este sábado Rusia acusó al
ejército ucraniano de atacar un hospital
en la zona Pro rusa de lugans donde
murieron 14 personas según informan las
autoridades de Moscú por otro lado kiev
anunció la muerte de tres civiles
resultado de una nueva ofensiva rusa con
misiles en el este de odoniesco
devastación en las calles de consta la
ciudad del este de Ucrania fue alcanzada
por misiles rusos el sábado tres
personas perdieron la vida Mientras que
otras quedaron en medio de los escombros
incluido este hombre que sólo recuperó
la matrícula de su coche algunos
tuvieron suerte de estar fuera de sus
casas durante el ataque mientras que a
otros los tomó desprevenidos
[Música]
estaba sentada viendo la televisión la
televisión estaba allí
en un momento hay un fuerte ruido no
entendía nada cerré los ojos abrir los
ojos y todo había estallado
estaba cubierta de sangre
pásalo este nicopol en la frontera entre
los territorios controlados por Ucrania
y Rusia los constantes bombardeos de las
fuerzas rusas hacen la vida casi
imposible y hacen que algunos residentes
piensen en evacuar
no hay palabras para esto disparan todos
los días cada vez yo vivo aquí sus
disparos siempre pasan por encima de mi
casa siempre están volando
que disparan los cohetes no puedo dormir
cuando llegamos por la mañana solo
encontramos cenizas no tengo nada que
decirle a esa gente son inhumanos y no
hay nada que decirle a esta gente
inhumana los ataques rusos se han
intensificado en el este y el centro de
Ucrania en los últimos días mientras
Moscú despliega el arma más eficaz de su
Arsenal contra los residentes los
ataques de artillería han dejado un
rastro de ruinas en muchas ciudades
entre ellas aquí en bulevar cerca de
donietsk Ucrania Confía en que el
aumento de la ayuda militar de occidente
anunciado esta semana como los tanques
estadounidenses abrams y alemanes
leopardos cambie la marea de la guerra
pero por el momento no sirven de
Consuelo a la asediada población del
este de Ucrania y un antiguo jefe del
ejército de la República Checa será el
nuevo presidente del país tras haber
sido elegido con el 57% de los votos en
la segunda vuelta presidencial unos
comicios con una participación récord de
casi el 70%. el presidente electo
exmilitar de la otan petre Pavel se
enfrentaba el multimillonario
andreys quien fue Primer Ministro del
país entre 2017 y 2021 y quien ya
reconoció su derrota Pavel cuenta con el
apoyo del gobierno de Centro derecha en
el poder entre otras cosas respalda a la
Unión Europea en su ayuda Ucrania
entiendo que haya algunos que estén
decepcionados porque no ganó su
candidato Favorito pero también veo que
en este país no tenemos votantes
ganadores o perdedores
veo que ganaron valores en esta elección
valores como la verdad la dignidad el
respeto y la humildad
me gustaría que él fuera el presidente
de todos los ciudadanos de República
Checa que viera sus problemas y luchara
por los intereses de la República Checa
me gustaría agradecer mucho a nuestros
votantes
y en otras noticias decenas de personas
de la comunidad indígena y anumami
ubicada en la amazonía de Brasil
necesitan atención médica por
enfermedades que aseguran están causadas
por la minería ilegal Se ha registrado
por ejemplo un repunte de malaria por
Trozos de agua estancada que deja la
explotación minera una situación que se
agravó durante la presidencia de Jair
bolsonaro rameiro cué Barberena nos
cuenta más
neumonía malaria diarrea infecciones de
piel y desnutrición infantil en
distintos grados la comunidad llanumami
de Brasil continúa sufriendo las
condiciones vulnerables de vida y la
ausencia de asistencia de salud
muchos están enfermos no hay comida
muchos de nuestros familiares han muerto
muchos ya no mamían muerto
se estima que 30.000 ya no mami viven en
el territorio indígena más grande que
tiene Brasil equivalente al tamaño de
Portugal y donde 570 niños han muerto en
los últimos tres años las enfermedades
del pueblo indígena desbordan la
capacidad del hospital de niños Santo
Antonio el único del estado de roraima
al que acuden en graves condiciones
menores que tienen entre 29 días y 12
años
las miradas apuntan a la aceleración de
la explotación minera que contaminó Ríos
mató animales arrebató fuentes de agua
potable generó charcos que originan
enfermedades y ocupa los pocos espacios
sanitarios
nos quedamos cuatro años sin asistencia
sanitaria en las comunidades 120
comunidades luchando por la vida más de
20.000 Mineros de oro en tierra indígena
yanomami con armas intimidando a las
comunidades comunidades que viven con
miedo
el último 20 de enero el Gobierno
Federal declaró una emergencia de salud
pública y desde entonces se tendieron
hospitales de campaña para auxiliar a la
comunidad la situación de los yanumami
se agradó seriamente durante el gobierno
de Jair bolsonaro durante su mandato las
muertes dentro del grupo indígena de la
selva amazónica aumentaron un 28%
Muchísimas gracias por su atención
llegamos así al final de esta edición
pero sigan con nosotros en France 24 y
24 punto com
[Música]